a United States Marine Corps aircraft
that sank during a training accident was
found overnight by the Australian Navy
family members have identified two of
the three Marines missing after the
accident they are corporal Nathan Ordway
and 26 year-old first lieutenant
Benjamin Cross they were among 26
Marines on board the Osprey aircraft
when it crashed off the Queensland coast
on Saturday 23 were rescued David Martin
is at the Pentagon David good to see you
good morning president Trump was briefed
on the crash on Saturday by his chief of
staff retired Marine general John Kelly
the three Marines are still officially
listed as missing but the search has
been called off and there is little hope
they will be found alive we have so many
awesome memories the family of first
lieutenant Benjamin Cross says the
26-year old pilot was a selfless man and
a dedicated marine to know that we will
never make any more with him is
unbearable cross was aboard an osprey
carrying 26 Marines as it attempted to
land aboard the amphibious transport
ship the USS Green Bay something caused
the Osprey to plunge into the water
about 30 miles off the east coast of
Australia 23 got out alive but three
Marines including cross did not make it
Marines with their tiltrotor aircraft
had just wrapped up a major exercise
with Australian forces and on Saturday
we're conducting training on their home
when the accident happened
the Ospreys sank to the bottom and it
will now take a major salvage operation
to recover it
the Osprey has been a controversial
aircraft because of accidents that
suffered during its development and
deployment
he was able to hover like a helicopter
and fly like an airplane by tilting its
rotor Marine Corps spokesman says that
since the aircraft entered service it
has a safety record comparable to or
better than other marine aircraft Tata
got a lot of bad publicity cross his
father Robert says his son thought the
aircraft was unfairly maligned he really
enjoyed flying it was something he
always wanted to do the wreckage has
been located and attempts to recover it
could begin as early as today but the
accident has raised fresh concerns about
the aircraft safety and on Sunday
Japan's defense minister asked the US
military to ground all Ospreys in Japan
Charlie David thank you